Arena crush is with us Arena welcome to
the show and congratulations a great
victory for you
today thanks guys I can't see you but
you know uh you know yeah we're a little
bit of a distance here it's an unusual
experience yeah you don't get that
intimate feeling that we usually get
when you're with us in the studio now
you will be able to see us as well tell
us about today's game I know it's been a
frustrating event up to this point the
first game you had a great position
against Karissa after that you saved it
so it kind of balanced out but finally
you got that elusive Victory tell us a
bit about that yeah definitely um last
few days were kind of disappointing
because I was also doing really well
against Talia and again like in the last
few moves before the time control I I
blew it um so obviously you know one of
the goals is not to get low on time
because I think that's really where I'm
going to give up points um of course
today's game was so complicated that it
was kind of hard to avoid the time
trouble even though I I was trying to
well fortunately at the end I still
managed to have a lot more time than my
opponent um her position was also not
easy to play and it was it was a it's a
game that I feel really good about
because you know you can win in a lot of
ways but you know this sort of way it's
like you kind of made your whole concept
work right that um I gave up my light
squired Bishop in order to keep my
knight on E5 and basically um you know
the way the game worked out was like
that's the uh culmination of that whole
concept from right from the opening y
absolutely and at this point you were
already breaking through we were looking
at your position at right now Rook takes
F7 was coming there were a lot of things
hanging in the air and that doesn't feel
like can we look at Rook h8 here because
because I actually realized you know one
of the things I realized that after a
rook takes F7 Queen F7 aha I have oh
Queen G5 right because you know at first
I didn't see this fork and F3 like I
literally was going to play Knight F7
and blunder this forks and that's why I
played King G2 on my next move that's
okay so this one was
yeah yeah don't touch that quick of
course I guess actually maybe I thought
her chance instead of G6 I don't know it
was G6 a mistake maybe she should have
played F6 there F6 was the best think
yeah she has to give up the queen right
like because I have to go for this line
and it's actually well okay I'm gonna
have to still to do a lot of work to win
um but okay it's not so easy for black
to let's say go for this because then
you really have to admit that you're
getting M it otherwise yes that's right
no uh very nicely played a beautiful
attack successfully conducted by you uh
Irena congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow unless we have other questions
from yaser and C no our congratulations
Arena something strange about today's
round lots and lots of decisive games uh
the tournament started slowly what
happened uh in this round three
everybody's suddenly swinging for the
fence
yeah I mean I guess after a few days of
calm it's kind of normal that we have an
explosive day right
yeah okay our congratulations
Arena thanks guys see you later
absolutely absolutely because